morgen ist es gerade das geheimnis des
spieles planeten und gerade deswegen
laden auch viele youtuber davon in
letzter zeit eine menge videos holen
sagt dann gibt es auch noch mich
ich hatte heute ein schneemann in meinem
playmobil kalender ist schon wie kegeln
hier mittlerweile spaß beiseite
allerdings würde lieben freunde ihr habt
es bereits im titel gesehen von einer
habt ihr euch heute recht herzlich
willkommen heißt und zu einer reaktion
von mir auf einem monat timing fails
compilation fanny best of both k
die heißen alle gleich und stellen sich
das nicht möglich
das so möglich ist dass man sich so
übereinander stellt dann okay jetzt
kommt zwar war udo also orange mit dazu
und die person die das films steht da
auch mit dabei agrarpolitik ems gekuckt
sah war udo wartet noch munkel ist jetzt
weg
passiert
[Musik]
hätte ich auch mal ganz schnell das
spiel verlassen
in diesem video geht es darum dass
electricals in der shell präsentiert
wird also wie es eigentlich immer in
electric läuft die person macht hier
seine tests oben in der elektrik
elektriker ist der tückische ort in
ganzen monats hier ist roth unterwegs
und anscheinend roommate
[Musik]
vor
das ist so richtig typisch luca wenn er
denn meint rosner werden würde
ok la hat orange getötet jetzt rüber in
horni in electric leinwänden okay es hat
geklappt jetzt hier wieder so tun als ob
man eh nicht da natürlich fixen
[Musik]
einerseits auf stumpf wird wenn du im
posthof und dann aber die leute denken
dass du im posta bist du bist aber auch
im post aber du hast die person
eigentlich nicht getötet
okay hier ist lila und wieder will
unbedingt rein in medway wahrscheinlich
weil ja genau die daten laufen die
ganzen einander vorbei
[Musik]
ok läuft hier wiederum in electric
herein der türkische ort macht hier
seine tests und gependelt
gelbes gewendet ist gestorben
warte mal gelb ist doch gerade gewendet
wie kann gelb wie kann geld denn dann
tot sein
jetzt wird natürlich wieder
rausgeschmissen es ist so typische
monats was ist hier rot ist ein paar dk
wie kannst du ihnen töten
ok ich brauche gar nichts sagen aber die
leute die das sprachenlernen nun noch
und dann gibt's großrazzia okay jetzt
will er den weg abschneiden zur
cafeteria weil er noch seinen kill
cooldown hart ich verstehe nicht warum
er nicht einmal die leiche selbst
gefordert und dann sagt das war braun
okay er spät sie türen aber hat noch
drei sekunden viel cooler und genau da
wird es auch darauf an gegeben und jetzt
mit brauner wahrscheinlich durchlaufen
und dann kommt wo ist dein braun
erst nach vorn und hinten keinen sind
frauen
warum herr z nein
toyotas gewettet ich dachte sie wird
genau dem moment getötet weit enteilt
sehr gut typische monatswert eigentlich
gewesen dass wieder rausgeflogen wir
jetzt genau
keine ahnung was jetzt passiert also
erst auf jeden fall im post
[Musik]
ja
das sind natürlich blöd hier ist jemand
der auf dem handy spielt und entdeckt
eine leiche und sieht dass die camps an
sind und er wird warum
dies macht 0 sind die person die das
ganze filmt ist im post macht seine task
bzw
das ganze hat noch vier sekunden kill
cooldown endet jetzt und will
wahrscheinlich rüber in
[Musik]
lärm zu lesen ist jetzt in security
tötet grün pink
es klappt halt immer in solchen top pick
raus es ist immer so in diesem public
lobbys menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend jetzt in workshops mit typisch
public lobby auch man solche leute hast
du in jeder lobbyist der post gibt
greenpeace alltags machen würde
augenscheinlich einem posta die frage
ist wieder erfolgreich sein
mit seiner taktik geht anscheinend sehr
bedacht vor sehr strategisch tötet jetzt
rot hüpften sven geht ok wieder zurück
in medway rain road wieder hinten raus
kann in 30 uhr wieder streit nachdem
stecke
so ist eckel ist so sei das bei
[Musik]
a
da das ist so bett timing in den shell
eine person beobachtet die security
teams und sieht wahrscheinlich ja
aber real tag achte die auf die cams ich
achte irgendwie nie auf die camps
[Musik]
wir stehen da und die stehen alle
dahinter kongress
ist halt alles gespielt aber eine
witzige idee hier läuft auch met ball
raus hat oben etwas werden wir daran
vorbeiläuft keine ahnung was seine
mission grad ist es ist wahrscheinlich
völlig locker läuft einfach
[Musik]
damit ist das dann der andere typ du
siehst auf einmal wieder umdreht grünen
befindet sich hier ein elektriker blau
dran
pro rot passt doch aufdecker das blöd
aber wahrscheinlich war es dann gar
nicht am ende
oder hat er einfach vergessen in dem
report button zu klicken guck mal keine
poster wie los ist kann man es einfach
bestellt sich einfach auf eine leichte
drauf bringen da ich meine echten leben
ist ja auch nicht daher und denkst du
auch hier liegt ein toter mensch da
stelle ich mich jetzt mal einfach mal
drauf anstatt ein krankenwagen zu rufen
habe ich das heute wieder nicht beenden
wenn ihr lieben freundes tut mir leid
dass jetzt der richtige klasse reaction
hier war allerdings war ich den
kompletten morgen mit alpakas spazieren
vielleicht habt ihr meine instagram
story gesehen es war unnormal niedlich
auf instagram ist auch neues foto online
gegangen könnt ihr euch alles gerne an
gucke ich heiß auf install laser lokal
so folgt mir da gern falls es noch nicht
tut alles junge lars schlecker
[Musik]